ich wurde von Miele zur IFA eingeladen
und durfte die verrücktesten
Küchengeräte der Zukunft testen
vielleicht hatte ich auch schon mal das
Problem dass sie eine Pizza ein bisschen
zu lange im Backofen gelassen hat so
dass sie am Ende schwarz rausgekommen
ist hier hinter mir ist eine und ich
kann den Live-View jederzeit gucken wie
sich mein Backofen Inhalt verhält also
wenn du unterwegs bist draußen bist und
deine Pizza fertig dann drückst du einen
Knopf und der Ofen geht auf und es ist
fertig Milad einen neuen Dampfbackofen
rausgebracht der sich einfach selbst
spült komplett mit Seife und allem drum
und dran ich glaube so ein Ding brauche
ich auf jeden Fall für meine Küche
komplett verrückt dieser Dunstabzug
fährt aus der Platte heraus auf dem
Kochfeld kann man überall seinen Topf
platzieren und das beste ist das ganze
funktioniert auch noch ihr habt gesehen
die Zukunft ist Kochens ist auf jeden
Fall wild ich bin gespannt was uns in
den nächsten Jahren noch erwartet